is I just think there's a lot of women  that have been brainwashed by feminism  and I did like the one thing that blew  up my channel was me red pilling women  and it was interesting because my friend  Jess who's my roommate it was like  that's how we kind of started I was  showing her Jordan Peterson about the  pay Gap I was showing her Thomas Sowell  where they talk about like how history  is misrepresented in something and it  was just so interesting for the audience  to see her like you know because she was  someone not that opinionated in the  middle and just changed her mind and I  would say of the girls I've done the  reaction videos with like I would say 75  become more moderate over time or change  their mind completely interesting